[Musique]
je m'appelle christiane fut 17 ans et
demi j'aime beaucoup lire je lis
beaucoup de poèmes en général de poèmes
de prévert verlaine rimbaud surtout
prévert c'est surtout un révolté c'est
ça qui me plaît je suis dans une école
d'arts graphiques parce que j'aime le
dessin je trouve que c'est une des
meilleures formes d'expression dans le
monde dans lequel on vit
parler c'est banal je ne sais pas si je
veux vraiment être dessinatrice
publicitaires
je crois que c'est aussi une sorte d'
exploitation des gens je saurai prise
dans l'engrenage et ça il n'y a aucun
métier qui permet de ne pas être pris
dans cet engrenage
la société d'une contrainte horaire on
est obligé qu'on le veuille ou non
d'être dans la société suivre le
mouvement et ça c'est tout le contraire
de la liberté et c'est peut-être pour ça
que je me nature parce que la nature
elle fait ce qu'elle veut elle est libre
la mort c'est toujours la nature
et comme j'aime la nature je n'ai pas
peur de l'amour il ya une phrase que
j'aime beaucoup et que je ressors
toujours la peur de la mort l'amour de
la peur et enfin la vie qu'est ce qui
fait que tout ça un jour ça a été donné
pourtant je ne crois pas en dieu mon
dieu à moi c'est la nature est immense
c'est beau j'aime beaucoup de clim
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on ne
fait pas partie du monde a dû j'ai
l'impression que même si c'est d'une
autre génération
il est plus près des jeunes que d'autres
adultes on a l'impression qu'il est au
dessus du monde et qu'ils observent avec
un microscope
j'ai l'impression que gotlib ces deux
personnages à la fois c'est le
personnage humoristique poétique qui
dessinent et de l'autre côté il y à un
homme qui vit dans un monde pourri on se
rend compte par ces bandes dessinées
qu'il aime les gens
j'aime les gens j'aime la vie alors je
crois qu'on se retrouve un peu
[Musique]
arabi est là
bonjour tous tianbao mais par moment
j'ai l'impression que tu prends tes
lecteurs pour des idiots coccinelle qui
commande tout l'enfer du toujours des
trucs que l'on se sent souvent oui peut
pas prendre les électeurs pour des
idiots parce que en réalité je travaille
pas pour les lecteurs je travaille avant
tout pour moi et c'est pas de l'égoïsme
c'est faux que ça me convienne à moi
enfin c'est à dire je travaille pour moi
et c'est un coup de poker que ça plaise
aussi aux lecteurs
et ça gêne pas que les gens interprètent
ce que tu penses de façon dit j'ai
jamais remarqué que des personnes
avaient dit pourquoi vous mettez
toujours un petit crocodile en bas de
nos plans alors cessons cac small a
dragon public et ses tarifs de 2 re lire
tes enfants demander si oui disons que
ça me fait marrer parce que je me dis ok
ce qu'il est con ce mec là d'avoir des
conneries pareilles et puis après je me
il ya peut-être un côté jubilation aussi
parce que c'est moi même qu'il l'ait
fait alors il ya un rire au 2e degré qui
provient du fait que c'est moi même qui
fut derrière clermont sorte
bon bah sexy des corps nus court-circuit
gotlib c'est très rare et court circuit
gotlib 6-3 mieres c'est lui enfin qui
s'y rendaient dans ses bandes dessinées
il ya souvent des personnages qui
reviennent ouais pourquoi moi j'ai pas
de héros du moins j'en ai pas eues dans
la rubrique à brac alors mes héros
c'était ses personnages qui revenait qui
constituait le lien entre d'une semaine
à l'autre
le que ce soit les aventures de machin
truc chouette il y avait
l'espèce de l'esprit commun et puis
alors pour marquer des jalons l'art y
avait notamment newton pour des brûlures
seraient une pomme sur la tête et ils en
déduisent est la loi de la relative la
loi de la dallas quand on appelle ça
avec mon rappel pire la pesanteur de la
gravitation universelle et après petit à
petit ça se déformer au fil des semaines
comme ça pendant trois bonnes années et
recelait des enclumes des animaux des
riens du tout et déduisait des bêtas
glow à ce contrôle alcool la répression
de l'ivresse publique en faisant
n'importe quoi qu on très vulgaire et
mellul guerre au sens large du terme
c'est à dire que bon quand un type fait
une grimace il a fait vraiment ou bien
les mains je dessine les ombles et
toutes les phalanges peut alors j'ai une
phalange est alors qu' il est il est
avant il était de bon ton de dessiner
une main plus puiser les gangs de
supprimer toutes ses rides et où
justement ces rites qui peut-être ajoute
une notion de vulgarité mais qui en même
temps dan de l'expression observer
beaucoup les fils que je peux absolue
j'ai pas le sens du décor de jeu passant
de la couleur je n'ai pas planter une
perspective tout comme ça donc petit à
petit j'ai tendance à éliminer les
décors et pour pas que ça fasse vide
il a fallu que je trouve d'autres choses
qui étaient dans mon tempérament
moi je vois la coccinelle qui est entre
entre toi qui dessinent et entre nos
lecteurs l'instant si la coccinelle
enfin comment on la sait faire que ça
en dehors et souvent beaucoup de bandes
dessinées sur toi pourquoi
j'aime bien raconter mes salades
peut-être que je suis un peu mégalomane
tu as fait une bande dessinée sur la
publicité destinée de critique et face à
voir si tu penses vraiment ça aussi
c'est exagéré tu parles sûrement de
cette bande dessinée où je n'arrêtais
pas de dire que la bande dessinée que la
publicité des quelque chose de l'ignoble
avec dany l'aliénation droite de crâne
et j'en profitais honteusement pendant
toute la pêche d'éclairement la
publicité pour mon iphone de la rubrique
alors que deuxième volume et ben ouais
mais ça résume en gros c'est à dire que
l'ensemble de ces deux choses là résume
en gros ce que je pense de la publicité
c'est à dire que c'est effectivement la
publicité c'est ça c'est du bourrage de
crâne mais d'un autre côté si on accepte
au départ de fonctionner dans un dans un
ensemble de sites de deux systèmes donné
ça devient difficile de rossi de refuser
un élément de ce système
en l'occurrence si j'ai accepté par
exemple qu'un éditeur publie un album à
moins je peux pas après lui venir lui
dire ne fait pas de publicité pour mon
album parce que vous allez bourrer le
crâne des gens vous allez les aliénés et
cetera et cetera
est ce que toi aussi tu fais partie d'un
mouvement de jeunes commise est
clairement les scouts
non j'aime pas le produit tandis que la
notion même de scoutisme
je suis contre le scoutisme parce qu'il
ya un arrière-plan de casernements et 2
de loi et de et de règles très strictes
de bonnes actions et de b à 5 des
actions et/ou de la culpabilisation dès
le départ avec les badges tout ça c'est
en fait le scoutisme faut pas oublier
que ça son origine dans la guerre
puisque c'est baden powell c'était
c'était une troupe militaire au départ
les scouts je crois au nom de la guerre
des boers une enfin tu n'es pas contre
les la réunion à lauren dunn
non non pas du tout
j'en mange pas mal bon bah non contraire
plus on est de fous et plus on rit là où
ça devient grave c'est qu'on n'est plus
on est tous et plus on s'emmerde
qu'est ce que tu penses de ces journaux
qui exploite le sexe pas tout ce qui a
de porno alors les journaux de bandes
dessinées à la loi je vais prendre un
exemple en présence de mon avocat
j'ai fait des trucs qu'on attend depuis
si jeune à l'idée de dessiner le
ministre la culture dessinera en
coccinelle ou comment les scouts
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'abord un
ministre de la culture ça exige notre
ministre est la clé ça existe
[Musique]
j'en ai besoin
en tournée je t'écoute un bon gars que
ça ça me proposait de rentrer à
l'académie qu'est ce que tu dirais à
l'académie française oui oh oui
marchera tout de suite non ces petits
annonceurs et ça dépend qui serait le
discours d'introduction
je voudrais bien que ça soit générale
plus tôt
je crois qu'il ya deux ou trois généraux
à l'académie française archives g
me souviens plus de biens de leurs noms
ou alors pagnol ou andré roussin un mec
comme ça
là oui ça serait chouette si c'est pas
et je marche maintenant il faut que je
sois générale serait génial
ecclésiastiques et vas-y tu es aussi
drôle dans la vie quotidienne que dans
seulement pire
moi je pense que l'humour c'est une
façon rester jeune auteur fait d'accord
l'humour implique que on est con et
plonger dedans soi même quand on en fait
quand on se dit maurice touché pourquoi
par rapport à 10 est encore à l'esprit
qui est plutôt un jeu soit sous forme de
boutade soit sous forme de deux textes
spirituels la notion d'esprit
ce qui fait d'ailleurs que très souvent
dans l'esprit il n'y a pas le côté noir
alors que dans l'humour ya l'humour noir
l'humour cruel l'humour grinçant
parce que quelqu'un qui fait de l'humour
peut être un très très grand pessimisme
j'aime pas beaucoup ce genre de
questions parce que si je dis je me sens
mal
on a toute ses dires alors que devant
que doivent penser les peaux malheureux
qui vivent dans les bidonvilles bien les
gens qui ne mangent pas à leur faim tout
est à juste titre si je dis je m'en sors
je me sens bien
voilà des gens qui liront sociaux ils
pensent pas ils sont pas mal de tous les
gens qui sont dans les bidonvilles etc
et toi tu te sens bien dans cette
société
pourquoi aurais-je et impression des
touches et non plus tous tes effet aidé
j'ai l'impression qu'au ni à des murs
alors pour lutter contre celle qu'il
faut faire maria deux solutions il ya la
solution par la politique et le
militantisme et qui a abouti à la
révolution bien alors il ya la solution
individuelle qui consiste en partant de
ce qui existe de seuil et de s'en sortir
on ne peut pas sortir je peux enfin on
verra quand on sera sorti nous racontant
ce rendez vous on sentira jamais sorti
rapidement
je ne peux pas c'est si bien pessimiste
ouais je sais pas si ça me fait plaisir
de rencontrer quelqu'un de plus
pessimistes ou là et la jeunesse comment
tu vas voir les là et les fils
maintenant font des trucs que l'on sait
quoi c'était faut qu'elle rentre
apprennent des choses discute de choses
aborde des problèmes qui pour nous était
vraiment des trucs dont on se foutait
éperdument et ça nous retombe sur le nez
après coup finalement et ces problèmes
là c'est bien de les aborder le plus tôt
possible
voici dommage que les jeunes soient
soient au courant de tous les problèmes
parce que ça leur retire leurs illusions
et au bout de enfin avant d'être
vraiment adulte ils n'ont plus du tout
d'illusions puis ils vivent dans le
monde réel ils n'ont plus aucune aucun
moyen de s'échapper mais je trouve moi
que c'est bien mieux comme ça parce que
justement ce principe des illusions
c'est un espèce de mythe un espèce de
truc
bidon et que comment dire ça ne sert
qu'à masquer des choses qui en réalité
ne doivent pas être masqué le plaisir de
vivre où le bonheur de ville ne doit pas
résidé dans des illusions et dwight doit
être dans les réalités tout en voyant
les choses en face nous voyons bien la
réalité
on peut très bien enfin avoir de réel
des illusions sur le futur se dire bon
ben maintenant c'est comme ça je suis
peut-être pas heureux mais peut-être que
ça va s'arranger dans 50 ans sera mieux
pour pas moi mes enfants seront heureux
mais je crois c'est ça qui oui ça sera
pas tout seul de toute façon ne s'est
pas en le relevant que ça elle fera faut
bien que tu maîtres du soutien pour ça
jusqu'au moment où on a l'espoir de voir
un jour des genres oui mais il faut que
tu aies participe à cela mais oui mais
l'espoir les ce moment là c'est pas
l'espoir l'espoir fait vivre ses parts
loin aucun si m pour bien commencer à le
réaliser
je suis pas recommandé de commencer à le
réaliser il faut se dire il faut avoir
une idée de ce que ce sera avant et
après oui c'est pas c'est pas sûr c'est
pas sûr on peut on peut se dire comme ça
quand il fait des dessins
quand il fait une bande dessinée tu pars
avant de dessiner contre eux tu sais où
tu vas arriver il va c'est la même chose
lui même le but de tailles variées le
but c'est de réussir sa vie c'est tout
sinon il ya ma vie c'est c'est être
heureuse et rendre les gens heureux de
ma très bien et bien d'un match en moins
contre moi aussi eh bien on est d'accord
je me pose quand 10 km heure je sais pas
si j'ai bien répondu en tout cas je
mange un bonbon
tu regrettes peut-être un peu d'être
adulte et qui parle d non pas du tout je
regrette pas d'être adulte non mais je
regrette de ne plus avoir la comment
dire espèce de liberté d'esprit d'être
plomb les enfants ses fesses d'amoralité
mais je pense que il n'y a pas à
regretter d'être adulte de toute façon
dans la dans la dia qu'une chose
d'absolument sûr c'est la mort tout le
reste c'est aléatoire qu'il a dit que
l'amour la mort la mort pour l'instant
jugeant pense pas grand bien je crois
qu'il apporte une solution puisque il
aide les jeunes à comprendre les adultes
peut-être que grâce à lui les jeunes
s'apercevront que les adultes sont pas
si idiots que ça quand je lui ai demandé
ce qu'il pensait la société n'a pas
vraiment répondu à la question mais je
crois qu'en réfléchissant bien on peut
arriver à à comprendre ce que c'est que
cette société pour lui il ne l'a pas dit
vraiment clairement mais il
lundi c'est une société qu'il n'apprécie
pas en elle même mais dans cette société
il a trouvé le façon d'être heureux
alors il s'en contentent ils n'ont pas
plus cette attitude peut paraître
choquant mais si gotlib et heureux comme
ça il fait mal à personne et puis il est
heureux mieux pour lui
c'est ça la liberté le fait qu'ils
soient qu'ils aient bien observé les
habitudes des gens ça vienne d'eux ce
qu'ils les aiment j'ai un bon sens qui
il m'a dit je parle de choses que j'ai
que j'ai à coeur mais je me rends compte
que les hommes et les incuries il aime
la ville aime les hommes il m'a dit
j'aime tout ce qui vit j'ai demandé
qu'est ce que la vie j'aime tout ce
qu'ils vivent
oh
[Musique]